vingt ans après que le gouvernement
québécois est adopté une loi pour
protéger les races patrimoniales
leur avenir est toujours loin d'être
assurée à tel point que le défenseur de
ces races demande qu'on accorde plus
d'égards et de moyens la sauvegarde de
ces animaux qui sont intimement lié à
notre histoire agricole entre-temps une
passionnée des races patrimoniales temps
de lui faire découvrir aux enfants à
saint-esprit dans lanaudière se cache
une ferme bien spéciale un sanctuaire
pour chevaux canadien vache canadienne
et pour la chanteuse claire des animaux
en voie de disparition
c'est aussi un camp de jour où mélanie
gagné apprend aux enfants tous les
secrets des races patrimoniales
c'est que je veux les faire découvrir
parce que sa salle aucun sens qu'au
québec on n'est pas au courant qu'on a
sur ces petits bijoux patrimoniaux le
qui sont entrain de sperme c'est que on
est à un cheveu de voir juste dans les
livres d'histoire ou les musées
un parfum de ps2 en fait un bond un bon
massage
si j'en parle aux enfants puisque ça
intéresse peut-être un ou deux ou trois
ou dix de ces enfants là à poursuivre ce
travail là bas on va arriver à quelque
chose
les amis aujourd'hui tu vas monter un
cheval bien spéciale qui va monter le
cheval canadien 1 2 3 etc au cauchemar
qui fait d'eux chose d'important il fait
assez fort pour travailler mais il est
quand même assez léger pour qu'on puisse
monter duré qu'une seule crainte qu'ils
mangent moins qu'un gros cheval mais qui
est capable de faire le même travail ce
qui fait qu'on lui a donné le surnom du
petit cheval de fer
ces coups là où j'avais parlé d'un
cheval de fantômes en cause que yo des
forêts sur leur pic pour expo main avec
l'avènement de l'automobile et la
mécanisation de l'agriculture
le nombre de chevaux canadien pur sang a
chuté ils étaient 24 milles au xviiie
siècle
ils ne sont plus que trois mille cinq
cents
là je vais te raconter l'histoire de ma
vache canadienne
[Musique]
cette vache rustique bien adaptée au
climat du québec a frôlé l'extinction au
cours des années 80 pourquoi c'est faire
passer en faire peur des races comme la
race austin une vache qui donne beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de lait on avait trois
cent mille vaches canadiennes maintenant
à rennes
[Musique]
il reste environ 3 ça mais la vache
canadienne elle fait pas d'eux est un
cas le pôle son bébé même temps puis
aussi elle à l'avant avec on croit moi
quand il ya un an 100 vaches canadiennes
ont failli être envoyés à l'abattoir
c'était le tiers du cheptel pur-sang de
la province
pourtant les vaches canadiennes tout
comme les chevaux canadiens et les
pouilles chanteclair sont censés être
protégés par une loi adoptée en 1999 qui
reconnaît qu'elles font partie du
patrimoine agricole du québec
ça a été vraiment le déclic que fait
comme faut faire quelque chose note loi
sur les races patrimoniales
elle est là qu une très grosse lacune
parce que l'oeil aux rien qui empêchait
l'éleveur ou l'abattoir d'accepter que
ces animaux là on n'a pas le droit
d'être le bâtiment patrimonial site
protégé pourquoi on peut pas faire la
même chose avec nos animaux il est
l'heure pour un effet
le ministère de l'agriculture des
pêcheries et de l'alimentation dont
relèvent les races patrimoniales n'avait
pas le pouvoir de racheter le troupeau
mélanie gagné a donc lancé un appel à
l'aide sur les médias sociaux pour
amasser les cent mille dollars
nécessaires on peut pas laisser soit
arrivée perdent plus de la moitié du
cheptel porcin de la race canadienne
ce serait assurément donné le coup de
grâce à cette race noc qui est déjà dans
une situation extrêmement précaire les
100 vaches ont finalement été racheté et
placés dans des troupeaux laitiers en
production mais les défenseurs des races
patrimoniales ont juré qu une telle
menace ne surviendrait plus jamais il
demande maintenant qu'elle bénéficie de
la même protection juridique que la
faune ou la flore par exemple si on veut
construire un hôte
et puis car qu'on découvre qu'il ya une
couleuvre
par exemple la couleur brune qui vit
dans ce secteur depuis que ce ne sera
sans péril
bon mais on va arrêter les travaux donc
il ya des démarches qui sont fait à ce
moment là pour cette faune delà puis on
voudrait que ce soit l équivalent pour
nos animaux du patrimoine pour assurer
leur survie
sera-ce doivent trouver leur place dans
la vie moderne
[Musique]
en ce sens c'est le cheval canadien qui
tire le mieux son épingle du jeu
depuis les années 90
l'espèce connaît un regain de popularité
grâce au sport équestre et le nombre de
pur sang et maintenant sable
tout le contraire de la poule
chanteclair cette poule issus de
croisements génétiques a été conçu par
un moine de l'abbaye d'oka au siècle
dernier la chanteuse clara elle a été
créée sur mesure
c'était pour régler le problème des les
gens avaient à l'époque les poulies
mouret l'hiver parce que leurs craintes
et leurs barbillons je les installe mans
alors le froid où il serait lui s'est
dit cissé seul problème
bah on va créer une poule qui en europe
son histoire captive les enfants nés
chanteclair e bay des québécoises les
oeufs le et ben non pas de baby schumi a
effectivement iris et il peut notre
souci tum plus que spécial schifrin web
puis les gens pouilly se sont pas ils se
sont faits créée par les autres poules à
20 malgré son histoire fascinante
la chanteuse claire appartient au passé
il faudrait 10 troupeau de 150
reproductrices pour sauvegarder la race
or il n'y en a aucun de cette taille en
production le dernier élevage
d'importance a été emporté par la
maladie il y a deux ans il ya une
éducation qui à faire avec ses ennemis
ou là puisqu'ils sont tellement rares
que peu de gens peuvent encadrer dans le
fond l'élevage de cercle les troupeaux
change cinq fois demain en trois ans
donc la constance est difficile à
établir
[Musique]
les silver encore en activité le font de
façon artisanale
combien unique valait 1 ingénieur en
informatique de saint-calixte dans
lanaudière
ils élèvent une centaine de poules
chanteclair par souci d'autonomie
de plus en plus on est très dépendant
des chaînes de production de notre monde
qui est très industrialisée mécanisée en
ce temps de coved on le voit vraiment
bien ou c'est aucun maillon qui est un
peu faible
il ya une cascade d'événements qui
arrive et tout d'un coup on n'arrive
plus à s'approvisionner convenablement
plus on est diversifiée plus on est
autonome aussi plus on est résilient
l'éleveur comparé la chanteuse claire à
la poule de bresse qui fait la renommée
de la gastronomie française
tout comme elle la cour chanteclair est
une volaille plus grosse a battu au bout
de 17 semaines comparativement à 6
semaines pour le poulet conventionnel
un pl est différent on plaît beaucoup
beaucoup plus coûteux au fait la viande
c'est pratiquement sûr le rouge
un peu comme le canada yannick vallée
vend ses yeux à la ferme depuis quelques
années mais il n'a pas le droit de
vendre son poulet en vertu du permis
qu'il détient les choses pourraient
toutefois changer le mapaq étudie la
possibilité de permettre à de petits
artisans comme lui d'abattre ses poulets
à la ferme et les vendre par la suite il
ne pourrait toutefois pas en élevé plus
de 300 donc c'est bien pour un marché
très très très locale si on pense que
les québécois moyen je crois qu'ils
mangent des tonnes de poulets chacun par
année ça fait pas beaucoup la dizaine de
personnes
il y en aura pas à l'épicerie
les besoins des restaurateurs qui
réclament cette volaille haut de gamme
depuis quelques années ne sont donc pas
près d'être comblé d'ailleurs le nombre
de poches en toc l'air pur sang élevé
dans la province n'est même pas
suffisant pour assurer la sauvegarde de
la race
malgré tout yannick vallée demeure
optimiste il ya deux avantages un goût
pour ce qui est local et je crois que
c'est ça qui va aider à sauver la pauvre
chanteuse claire il faut jeu on y arrive
à sauver nos belles races patrimoniales
puisqu'elle les jarrets oublie pas qu
ils correspondent plus aux marchés
d'autres productions tout seul mais ils
y ont leur propre créneau
puis faut juste les envoyer à la bonne
place les vaches canadiennes elles l'ont
trouvé leur créneau le relais plus
riches en matières grasses et en
protéines que celui les vaches austin
est désormais utilisé par des
fromageries de renom le fromage de lait
de vache canadienne a même été reconnue
comme une appellation réservée en 2018
comme l'agneau de charlevoix où le vin
de glace
le sort de la race semble stabilisé
alors qu'il y avait seulement trois
troupeaux en production commerciale il
ya deux ans on en compte désormais cinq
parmi ceux qui assurent la relève
le troupeau de mélanie gagné dont le
lait sera vendue à une fromagerie d'ici
un an
mais là maintenant chercher les produits
en épicerie ça va affecter parce que moi
tout seul en pack élevage peut pas
sauver les races il faut que j'intéresse
le consommateur il faut que le
consommateur ait un intérêt à aller à
l'épicerie paix a demandé les produits
de vache canadienne personnel
c'est une question de valeurs c'est une
question de
respect du patrimoine c'est pas fini
s'est rassis tellement pas fini encore
quelque chose à donner encore quelques
joueurs à porter entre-temps mélanie
gagné peut se vanter d'avoir transmis
aux enfants l'amour de ses bêtes ainsi
qu'une certaine compréhension de leur
généalogie le cheveu aussi le coup
d'oeil ou vaches puis
la vache c'est là le cousin emploi paca
c'est comme une histoire de famille
[Musique]
e